on this episode Ryan holiday brings his
wisdom
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
ah
this is
Gary B hey everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is episode 262 of
the askgaryvee show
I'm pretty excited about this Ryan
holiday is in the house I know that a
lot of you are humongous fans of this
man's work I've seen his name pop up now
for feels like about a half a decade I
like saying that instead of five years
I'm not sure why it is that what it is
yeah I like you know it's like it's like
Jake just said we'll be ready in 90
seconds instead of a minute half it
sounded shorter by the way for the
record Jake took a lot longer than that
but here we are refining loud 262 it's a
Monday gloomy in New York the New York
Jets just lost Quincy and none WA for
the season he was our only offensive
weapon though Bilal pal if there's some
other little pieces and she looks decent
but like the Jets are well on our way to
a historically bad offensive season so
that will be fun to talk about through
the fall as we are now in August which
means it's October that's how I
basically think about August because
August is kind of weird you kind of come
back it's really September never
September 1st because Labor Day is
always later it just it's odd it's
October and we have a lot to do but Ryan
why don't you say hi to the vaynernation
and for the couple of them that don't
know who you are what is the kind of
three minute to minute bio all right I'm
Ryan so I've written a bunch of books
six books thirty so six books before I
was 30 dropped out of college at 19
worked for Robert Greene or at the 48
laws of power or for Tucker max wrote I
hope they serve beer in hell
by 21 22 as a director of marketing at
American Apparel which is at one point
the largest fashion brand in the United
States and then I started a company
that's work as authors like Tony Robbins
Tim Ferriss Cole lapin dozens of New
York Times bestsellers millions of books
and then I just work on cool projects
now that I like and that company brass
tech brass check yeah I don't say the
name because I actually don't really
want any clients but that's the name
so you prefer no client no no I prefer
picking your client I prefer not to have
incoming business only because you don't
want the emails to say this is the book
you'd like to be more selective yeah I
think you're trying to control the top
of the funnel it's top of the funnel and
I think as you see with get with
vaynermedia it is a lot of work to scale
an agency and what I really love doing
is writing so I want to work on products
I want to work on so if I feel like
spending the next three days writing
something I don't have anyone I have to
answer to when did you realize you liked
writing I don't know I wasn't one of
those kids that like always wanted to
write I think I fell in love with books
and it wasn't until I met Robert Greene
that I realized like you could make a
living doing what he was doing that you
could you could be a nerd about history
and philosophy and all these things and
and that you didn't have to be a
starving academic you could reach
millions of people you know Robert
Greene's books are so popular they're
actually banned in most federal prisons
because they think that it makes
prisoners too violent and give them too
many ideas about how to be powerful so I
did and you know what 50 wrote a book
with 50 cent and he he that's the life
that I want I want to make things that
have impact but also are the things that
I'm fascinated by so how's that going
it's going great I mean you know in 2014
I wrote this book called the obstacles
away which the New England Patriots read
on their way that hold on hold on you
know you're about to end this interview
very very very very quickly no no I know
we I'm sorry I can see your head working
here I know you've limp you've landed
this sentence with purpose I just want
you to know that I'm willing to end a
sentence with purpose funny character
kiss okay maybe we maybe we can use a
different example other teams have
enjoyed this book I note of this yes
Melissa give ll see there we go I like P
Carol former Jets head coach yes that's
true also former Patriots coach though
that's true but it's a terrible in
England so I prefer that so so I wrote
this book about ancient philosophies
yeah
a Bible and professional sport yes which
is what that is just amazing to me I
just love it I love I love being able to
take something that I'm interested in
that I'm fascinated but that I could
nerd out about all day and translate it
and bring it to an audience that
wouldn't think they're interested in and
in that form do you think of yourself as
a translator as a DJ as somebody who
synthesizes yeah I think that's what
we're all doing right there's no new
idea it's right every everything was
said by Aristotle or the the Romans or
the Greeks and I want to take I want to
take those ideas and present them in a
new way and I think I think there's an
immense amount of value and not a lot of
competition in people who make
connections between two so it's not just
translating one old idea in a new way
but taking two old ideas and combining
them together into a new idea I think
that's very important like that so
what's what's uh obviously you know
before we started this you gave me a
little insight into a book you're
working on but let's shelve that for a
second Oh Sheldon I guess uh what if you
were like - what what I'm very
interested in people's pulse on culture
and like life and and themes like what's
what's what's got your attention right
now in the world is it like slime
selling on Instagram like it is for
Kastner over here you know is it the
Jets historically bad often it's like
what's it what's on your mind my answer
is going to be weird died but I spent
the last two weeks repairing fences on
the ranch that I live on
so I've been thinking nothing about I've
been thinking about nothing that's going
on in the world except for had a hand
barbed wire and prevent cows from
escaping and how did that go you know
what I what I've loved this is what I
was thinking about is that like I didn't
check social media and this time yep I
was I was totally I was focused on
assault yes and and and that this was
the opposite of the work that I normally
do is incredibly fulfilling and
satisfying it was super narrow right
very minor like kind of hint like just
three days on and and I was telling
someone it was like it doesn't it
doesn't require
to be smart it just required you to be
tough and discipline and discipline
right like you can learn how to do it in
two seconds but then you got to go in
and get scratched up and be out in the
Texas heat and do all this stuff so I'm
interested in I think we're going to see
a I think social media is clearly here
to stay but then also then you feel the
full digital emergence is going to allow
us to get excited about these kind of
tasks yeah as an outlet to balance of
the full 24/7 on on on on on world yes
and I also think Millennials especially
are going to be the first generation to
really tire of these things and go stat
and find some bit like what I'm doing is
of both absurd and totally financially a
drain right to own cows is like the
worst business in the world yes but but
you love cows I don't love cows I mean I
love the land and being outside and
doing all that what understood there
it's romanticizing the past right like
my parents and grandparents and there
they were like I just got like do you
think about the America two generations
before they're like I've got to get off
this [ __ ] farm right like I wanted on
the fence yeah well you know what's so
funny about that I think that's like
that's always the advice when I give
when somebody's trying to think up
something it's always pulling in the
opposite direction of the current fast
trend Yeah right like snapchats
restrictions were a great answer to
Twitter and Facebook
openness right so like that makes a ton
of sense to me and as a matter of fact I
actually see it in a similar way with a
slightly interesting twist
I'm fascinated that so many people are
doing real-life stuff only to then take
the picture and use it as the PR like
people are literally hiking this weekend
just for the shot
to put on Instagram but it's forcing
them to do old school [ __ ] yes yes
because no one wants to see another shot
of your dinner because I or if it is if
it is a shot of your dinner you better
have cooked it and shown us the whole
process of you doing it and why you did
it and all that people people will we'd
rather see somebody pull out carrots
from the ground right now then the
finished carrot glaze dish yes we're
just exhausted with the same scenes we
saw over and over to find demand of
attention Andy let's get some phone
calls going in here
uh Ryan so many of the people that are
watching that are in the digital
marketing space know you for your
awesome abilities in this world what's
you know have you kept up with the
ability of being good at digital
marketing like do you feel like that's
always in your mindset or how do you
think about that world growth hacking
things of that nature yeah I mean it's
all I think about especially because I I
have to eat my own dog food right if I
don't know how to market my books don't
sell my products don't sell you know so
definitely and actually I think this
goes to your point though I think from a
marketing standpoint people tend to it's
like Oh everyone's on snapchat I got to
go on snapchat right and and I think
there's a huge mover advantage if you're
the first on a platform you can rake up
a lot of games and then I see people
giving these sort of wars of attrition
instead of trying to do the thing that
no one else is doing
I totally agree like like it's probably
not it's you know I've been spending a
ton of time thing about email because
email is not dead
and nobody in the best minds tend to not
be spending their time on it when the
thing nobody knows nobody owns email
right so there's no networking how do we
monetize allow that hello how are you
this is Gary me and Ernie askgaryvee
show with Ryan holiday that's so awesome
Haley hi Ryan hi you have done it where
are you from and what's your question um
I I live in Jackson Hole Wyoming and I'm
an artist and so I just started being a
full-time artist this summer I feel like
illustrations and watercolors yep and so
I'm we're watching we're watching your
movie watching your pineapple and
flowers right now oh gosh cool yeah so
um that's just some quick stuff I don't
worry don't hedge do not hedge [ __ ]
awesome I can't do it keep going what's
your question yeah I kind of think
you're gonna listen I exactly asked but
I just what I wanted to know what how so
right now like I have a lot of clients
that are just like commission-based and
it takes a lot of time and I'm trying to
get to the point where I can like make
this more sustainable than spending all
my time
right you don't want you don't want
science you want to get to a place where
people want to buy your [ __ ] for a lot
of money right yeah yeah Ryan you're the
first swing at this yeah another well
first off I would think to the chicken
Haley I would think about charging with
if you're doing stuff on Commission that
should be incredibly expensive and then
that way there's no that's not on
commission can be more can be cheaper
but then scale more so I'm always if
it's just going to be you if you're not
trying to build this huge organization
around you you you want to be exclusive
and you want there to be value in that
exclusivity so that's how I would think
about it
Haley I do that by making an interesting
point I'll tweak on it have you
continuously charged more every time you
got a new client I've been trying to
lately
but I've kind of like I'm also as a kind
of scary like the point I'm at I feel
like I don't know if I have enough
client base to move up further than I am
right now and how long have you been
doing this it's been a hot you don't
used to do fashion design so it's been
kind of a hobby on the side for probably
about five years I've been doing
separate clients and then just this year
I started to raise prices like very
slowly and so and how also many hours a
day are you spending on quite it I mean
probably half the day every day would a
half the day by your definition I'm
probably eight eight hours is you is you
painting right right and what you
happening with the other 16 hours in
your day um I have another part-time job
good and then I guess I guess I get I
suppose I get sidetracked with social
media as well respect 140 on six so
instead of building sentences you're
just going through your feed yeah and
then I think I also get sidetracked
trying to figure out what Avenue to go
towards avenues affordable avenues those
gateways to new clients
right yeah have you me I have you have
you made spec pieces for people with big
social followings and just sent it to
them as gifts or DM em or have you gone
down that route that has been a real
good hack for a lot of artists I mean
every time I get something I throw it on
the back here like has that been part of
the acquaintance not every time one
every ten times back to why it's hard
have you have has that been part of your
equation it's been a little bit I
actually did that with Pat Flynn earlier
this year and I I went to him and
painted him a mural but I've had good
luck with that but I'm finding a hard
time I guess now that you pointed out
that I have a lot of extra hours I could
do more well look if you're having I
think the other thing I find is like
people are like oh I'm having luck with
that and then they don't go all in on
the strategy right like if it's all
working yeah and you want to grow your
business do more of the stuff that's
working I love you so much
ride for that literally if I was a
painter I would only paint influencers
on Instagram and DM people literally I
wake up in the morning at 7:00 a.m. p.m.
until I got blocked from people like
that set that and I probably create like
11 accounts to continue to DM and would
say hey you know you know you know hey
Jake benroubi
you know I like your style can I make a
piece for you and literally do that and
it's great the castner's here because he
was with me when I was in the early days
of digital where it was exciting for me
to sit and cold email p.m. create forum
names and become part of the community
to bring awareness to something that I
was willing to over deliver on right and
so like I think he should spend two
hours DMing people and saying I'd like
to make a piece of art for you right
making your time in your feed and social
media worthwhile hit the explore feed
click things that are inviting you see
people that have big followings and then
DM them and say I'd love to make a piece
for you right and then one out of every
two will feature it and one of every two
will just hang it without anybody seeing
it right and you do a thing that most
people don't do right most of the people
online are like hey can I write an
article value can I have you on my
podcast all this thing that takes time
for them you're making a physical
product like how many people have
paintings that someone
made for them unsolicited wait it's
there because you don't get a lot of
ratted correct and you know who outside
Marc Marc Ecko who we both know yes you
literally launched echo industries which
became a billion dollar company by
making a swag for people in hip-hop he
made it he made a jacket for Spike Lee
yep about Malcolm X yeah I actually talk
about the story in my book perennial
celery but he talks about it in on label
about he calls them swag bombs and he
would make amazing stuff for people and
send it to them and this airbrushed
jacket launched a 20-year relationship
that he has with Spike Lee Haley listen
influencers on Instagram are underpriced
by their attention somebody that you
make a painting for that has a million
followers still thinks it's cool for now
that you made a painting for them and
they're going to post it on their
account and that is going to bring you
disproportionate awareness I highly
recommend you going deep on this
strategy by business developing for
people to don't do it on spec and send
it to them and then you know it be raw
takes it home you know actually figure
out they're interested by it and then
and then they actually showcase it and I
would rent to Ryan hit them I'm having
luck with this and not doing anything
with it like the one thing my team will
tell you a lot of them are here is soon
and I know you move this to as soon as
we see something works I squeeze the
living [ __ ] out of that thing until it
doesn't work no more okay got it
alright good good call yeah thank you
good call I like that you can get the
next one uh Andy right that's such a
good point right like isn't that the
point right like I think one of the
things that has always been interesting
about me is I love the unscalable so
much so that I think ironically what
doesn't make me best-in-class then
growth a lot of times has been I don't
pass it on to the scalable technology
thing cuz I love the dirt so much for me
I watch everybody any other way that you
know like ya know I mean when I sit down
with clients my first question is always
what where most of your clients coming
from and then they're like
this and then I go so let's do more of
that no like thank you this is a great
idea and it's like you were literally
already doing this but I'm just going to
talk to you about how we can double down
and put more resources behind it or
whatever so here's something people
don't realize in the CPG world like the
deodorant shampoo soda it's all heavy
users like 10% of the users drive the
entire business so if you quadruple down
on that base and get one more
incremental hello this is Donald Donald
this is Gary Vee and your knee
askgaryvee show with Ryan holiday oh my
god I'm here cooking Edgar my kitchen
I'm watching it was so thanks for but
how are you we're great
where are you from Sarasota Florida
London what's your question my man I
don't really have a question man I just
want to tell you I just you're a huge
inspiration to me my family I'm in the
family business of dry cleaning my
parents came down from New York and 89
two thirds so then kind of built this
thing from the ground up thought five
years ago I started to build like a free
pickup and delivery service on this side
of our as an extra added service to our
business and I don't know I just
it starts Darrell this year we're going
to break 700,000 and just want to let
you know man you're just a huge
inspiration through the hustle and uh
it's really appreciate everything that's
very very kind can you say something
nice about Ryan that's right you'd like
a great guy I don't he's really
good-looking a great guy listen thank
you so much for calling man that means a
lot to me
right there you're welcome that's good
Andy I like the strategy more of those
just random phone calls of compliments
and we don't have to do it perfect
exactly no worries
I'm not doing nothing you've done a good
job at this point Ryan what uh what
about what was the first breakthrough
hack or growth or thing that happened in
your kind of careers of teenager or
young man or like what was one of your
favorite like tripling down on something
or discoveries you know Eric Kastner
again I love referencing he helped me
build winelibrary.com along with John
Kay and we were hacking me AJ and him
one summer we create a cycle tag my for
my it was a myspace tool we're making
all the money in Adsense and
accident we would post on celebrity's
walls a link out to us and we do by hand
by accident AJ left one of these in the
harf href right he left the cat what is
the care like the the bracket out or any
control copy by accident what it did on
my space was it made our post which
usually you would post but then a
million people would post some Justin
Timberlake's wall and you get pushed to
the bottom for some reason with AJ
posted this without that bracket it got
stuck above the wall and and was stuck
for like an hour as a top post and it
exploded our site it's always one of my
favorite moments in the history of me
being like is just super funny how about
for you real quick before we get to know
more sculpt if we forget how quickly
that like my face basically disappeared
because it was so shittily made correct
do you know what I mean it basically is
flawless and that's why it won and it
was funny everybody's reaction Facebook
was like wait I can't customize my wall
like this sucks that's why you can't
customize your wall Rex [ __ ] breaks off
what that's right when I was in America
pear one of the strategies to be sort of
figured out very early on was okay if
you're boring you have to pay a lot of
money to get your advertisements in
front of a lot of people yeah right and
that's why banks spend billions of
dollars on advertising even insurance
companies exactly so if you're boring
you pay a lot yes if you're interesting
or provocative would you piss people off
you get tons of attention and those same
ads that you would normally have to pay
to get people in front of the media will
report about and write about for free
right and so the idea was if we're let's
say we're going to spend ten thousand
dollars on advertising on this thing
well how can we do it in such a way that
it creates a news story or creates
attention in and of itself so I think
people are always people are there's
what I figured out is there's basically
two ways to efforts one is direct
response which is very boring all about
conversion and you got to know that and
and math exactly and you can pretty much
outsource that to like this is what I
want this what I'm willing to spend
someone does that and then the CEO or
the leadership of the company because
you can't have someone making these
decisions for you what are we willing to
do what are we willing to say what
statements are we will
to make and that's what can catapult you
from a tiny company - American Apparel
was a six hundred million dollar company
but it had the profile of a six billion
dollar company because we took risks we
took stands and we did things that other
brands were afraid to do you could argue
that it has some consequence for other
reasons and we won't get into that but I
think people spirit of its right I mean
yeah humans behind it can create
vulnerabilities yeah and you got you
know it's why controlled chaos is always
so powerful right if you have somebody
that has that artistic practicality
right right yeah you look at someone
like Trump right it good political you
know whether you agree with him
politically or not he by saying the
things that other people are afraid to
say he gets way more attention than they
do and he reaches people that they're
unable to reach supply and demand of
important like attention and information
or words to write about things people
don't realize this the media has an
insatiable appetite and if you make
yourself appetizing don't don't jump all
of you
first um what's interesting is in
traditional PR there was a gatekeeper of
that but now the people that are
interesting can go direct to consumer at
scale you can regular you can announce
your own campaign on medium and if it's
provocative and interesting
Jenica yeah looks like Jovan [ __ ] up
let's move on those of Shaban call back
okay
all right let's just move on um so what
about audio while he's transitioning out
right now obsessed with Alexis kills you
know Google home podcasts just the fact
that I believe that audio and sound is
saving people time because you thought
your phone
yep so where have you been on that have
you been looking at that at all like
what's your relationship with the track
state of audio I think uh I think
ideally hello why hello come on excuse
me you call me people yes this is gary
veenstra from the askgaryvee show I
called you
oh yes are you would you like me to call
you was that part of the plan
gave us on your phone number what plan
Elvis thing off I'm sorry oh hey this is
Jerry's leadership from the askgaryvee
show
yes boy calling from yeah I'm calling
from the askgaryvee show my name is Gary
Vaynerchuk did you put your phone number
on my live stream so we would call you
oh we put our number on we're on
Facebook on Facebook is that true or is
it the wrong number I think it's the
wrong number
no problem I hope you have a wonderful
that yeah we are desperate here I'm
sorry about the no assurance where what
where are you huh we are in LA very nice
well hope you have a wonderful time
sorry Pinkamena su thank you thank you
so much you're welcome
okay bye bye good night all right no I
think I think I think audios huge
because it's one of the unlike video and
unlike reading you can do another thing
while which is huge right and as we have
become those humans we are more and more
attracted to yes and also if it's
long-form for the most part and I think
one my first book was sort of an expose
of how toxic so which one is trust mem
line with an exposition of the problems
in the media system and I think one of
the reasons that podcasts are so good
and audiobooks are so good is that
they're not subject to the Darwinian
economics of viral myths right podcasts
don't go viral that's why unless it's an
amazing world but for the most part or
not reverse engineering a headline to
create virality regardless of the depth
of the content underneath it yeah it's
either just a long conversation or deep
dive in their subject you start up is 10
episodes you have an hour long it's the
number your Diaries yeah so it's been
it's so much higher quality than most of
the crap on the internet and I think
that's huge
do you believe in the current state of
the internet the best quality rises to
the top no of course not yeah I think I
think there's that Martin Luther King
line where the arc of history is long as
it's been
is towards truth yes at the end of the
day yes great showing a demand for the
audience but there are many many amazing
things that are not being seen over a
lot of crap hey it's Gary Vee your knee
askgaryvee show with Ryan holiday what's
up Ryan what's up Gary how's it going
hey no man who's this you know what this
is Kyle and Jung over in Los Angeles
over at the shoot house thing in Melrose
actually that's awesome Colin thanks man
thanks for coming out what's your
question my question is if you're so
developing a business like in the sense
of does that work full-time my marketing
agency which I love have left I'm here I
think we're actually gonna do some
partnerships with vaynermedia some of us
have some meetings over there but on the
side I've been building some tech
company to help small businesses save
money been building a personal brand for
creating content kind of no exact
direction on whatever business like I
don't know what it is I want to go 100%
in on what is that what that's going to
be like the main focus so how do you
during that time do you still build like
a personal brand like like should I have
I know you talked about making a vlog
and they're here to talk a lot about
building up your own content is that
something that I should be doing even
though I don't know what the exact
direction I want to go yeah so I'll let
Ryan answer from his perspective because
it's going to be an interesting one you
know as long as you're hearing me loud
and clear when I talk about documenting
versus creating the thing that I'm so
worried about in this whole personal
brand thing is it gets real ugly real
fast because people lie right because
you start faking it too you make it and
you start fronting and the reason I'm so
happy that I had that meeting with that
kid and it caught some wind and gave me
clarity around this documenting versus
creating like I was a very different guy
in a lot of ways when I was 22 23
starting why am i right and but in a lot
of ways I was a super similar guy right
Eric and so so like I couldn't speak to
a lot of the accomplishments I had
because I hadn't achieved them yet but
[ __ ] man I had plenty bravado and it was
fun it would have been fun to be able to
call those shots back in the day it
would've been cool to see that meeting
that Eric and I had with David Karp
tumblr you know in our office like you
know I guess back it's funny that what
would Ryan was saying right before he
called my big thing is the truth right
like you can build your personal brand
aka your reputation you can hack with
creating content I'm just worried that
people when they think personal brand
start calling themselves like the
seven-figure expert or like I feel like
everybody turns into WWF and has to
become a character not their actual
person so I yeah I'm a fan of it because
I think it leads to opportunity I think
like it's a it's a living breathing
resume at scale that has huge upside one
piece of content away from changing your
life as long as you're patient and
realize nobody gives a [ __ ] for the
first two three four or five years
depending on how interesting you are and
what you're producing and it has a lot
of people I mean the most of the market
is producing stuff that nobody wants to
watch right yeah so I'll tell telcos
right in the late 1920s 1930s Winston
Churchill is basically driven from
political life in Britain right he
worked his way all the way up to the top
one of the most important people in
Britain and he's driven out from
politics he still holds a small office
but he's driven out and what does he do
he turns to radio and writing articles
he writes hundreds of articles he gives
international radio broadcast he's
actually at this time more famous in
America than he is in his own his home
country he writes books he writes this
epic series about the First World War
and about the the history of the English
language and all these things he builds
a huge platform becomes a media company
himself basically yeah and he's
publishing in Ladies Home Journal in the
United States and everywhere anywhere
that will take him any big lover sunja
nears the content for the context of the
place yes about all he becomes a famous
person who has a platform and so he and
he begins to warn about the threat of
Nazism and Hitler which people in the
British leadership leadership was
ignoring and so finally when they woke
up and they realized we've been
appeasing Hitler for all this time we've
not been taking this seriously and they
said and the people wanted the person to
replace them to solve this problem that
they'd avoided for so long Winston
Churchill was the name on everyone's
lips right
and he had he had the world's ear to
communicate that message and see so it's
never too late or too early to start
building your platform and you have to
do it you know uh Ryan just much more
articulate explained the way I talk
about being historically correct the big
reason I have so much passion right now
documenting everything I'm doing is
because historically I've been right
about a lot of stuff and those are
missed opportunities for me and I've
been wrong Eric remembers when I thought
video email would rule the world but I
like being wrong to you know to me what
was refined at 41 year old Gary that 25
year old Gary didn't have is I try not
to predict as much what Winston
Churchill didn't make up he wasn't
Nostradamus he was like a man named
Hitler is going to like he wasn't doing
that weird thing right he was just
watching and social commentating in real
time that's what I've evolved into
instead of predicting that video emails
going to win I just recognize that voice
is working that podcast consumption is
unknown it's just being first faster and
making a bet in the early indicators
instead of guessing and so I think
that's what you're speaking to and going
directly to the people building an
audience you know people people think
like oh when I have my company or I
write my book or I make my youtube
channel or start my pocket that's what
will get me the audience it's got a
layer I don't give a [ __ ] what Drake has
to say now I would watch every minute of
the three years before he became Drake
all of it I would consume all of it
show me the day before it happened and
then you realize it's not a day the
biggest reason I'm doing daily V is
because guys YouTube it's not a day
before it's the whole thing it's just a
volume of work that shows you it wasn't
a moment it was the whole [ __ ] thing
the whole process and so no man I don't
think it's too early as long as you're
not full of [ __ ] and so as long as your
content is I'm not sure what I'm doing
yet or today I eat a banana or it's
really cool today that like everybody in
this room and everybody watching right
now and everybody on YouTube coulda gave
their two cents the day Instagram copied
all of snapchats features a year ago it
would just be fun to see whatever
but he thought how do they feel how did
your mind change like that's just
interesting fodder and if you find out
that eventually you're right at social
commentating - Ryan's point you're the
name on everybody's lips yeah and I
would say also your point about
documenting my friend Austin Kleon he's
a great writer and artist he says you
know you can't it's not a too many
people want to be the noun without doing
the verb right so you got to do you got
to do the work it's about showing the
work that you're doing not talking about
what that works got you or I hate fake
it till you make it but no you shouldn't
have to fake it to you maybe you should
be showing uh showing yourself making it
right that's interesting you know and
then you have a huge audience like me I
prefer the climate not the finish line I
don't like the World Championship I am
disgusted when the Yankees and Rangers
finally win and focus completely on the
Jets like I'm sorry like you don't
understand how excited I am for this
[ __ ] season I cannot wait to go there
every Sunday and get our faces beaten in
because I want to sit there lonely
because it's gonna be a half-empty
Stadium and I'm going to watch and I'm
gonna look at everybody's [ __ ] face
and I'm going to look and then 5 7 9
years later when those seats are filled
with new faces I may be like you weren't
[ __ ] here but Rick was and I love
that process and I think way too many
people want to be the thing and not
realizing the thing that attracts us to
each other is the vulnerabilities and
the humility and the process not the end
result after their fact if you think
about hip-hop do you know why I love
hip-hop once you're a star you're only
writing about how you got there like
what are you even talking about all your
ever talk to it notice what comes out of
my mouth the first time everybody who's
a fan of mine does not watch the first
five minutes of any my keynotes because
I have to drill home I was born in
[ __ ] Belarus there was a studio
apartment is a [ __ ] Lemonade Stand
there's baseball cards like everybody
knows it because it's my favorite part
and people don't realize you're so lucky
that you now live in a world [ __ ] man if
I had this Ryan you know [ __ ] awesome
this would have been making videos in my
dorm room at [ __ ] Mount Ida college
with all these [ __ ] users around me
and me just making videos like I know it
looks bad now
but it's gonna get [ __ ] unbelievable
like you know and that's it and so like
- I love July Hooper answer I mean I
think we're learning out with each other
a little bit I think we forgot you're
here but I hope this is bringing out I
hope this is bringing you value in kind
of the essence and energy that we're
bringing to the conversation and you got
to love that out you got to love that
process right you got to love it like
when I have a book I have a book come
out the date almost on my last four
books the day the book came out I was
working on the next one because there's
pleasure in me sitting there with the
page and moving things around and
watching the Amazon rank or the reviews
all that makes me uncomfortable and and
it's out of my control
the work is always in my control I can
make it good I can't make people do
anything yeah and so for me like it's so
interesting like I get super excited
when I have an idea for a book and then
because I don't actually write I have a
go so I have a different process um for
me as you could imagine opening like
when I start selling it which is usually
three months before it comes out and
then opening day like to me that's what
I get excited about I I secretly think I
can make people do what I know but I
mean no I'm joking but I'm mixing I win
the national championship he walks he
celebrates on the field and he walks
into the locker room and he's thinking
about next season and that it I get it -
I hate winning I really do I really I
don't think people realize how much I
mean that I like the process over
everything and and I but that and that's
what made you good at the process but
it's an adaptive mechanism right because
you love the process that's where you
spend all your time and energy in you it
feels comfortable and you're at home in
it and the winning even if you're
winning a lot winning is rare right like
even if you're winning all the time it's
every couple months over a couple weeks
but every day I'm sitting down I'm I
could have my routine in my video so
that's what I love too long what did you
get out of this are you talking to me
I'm telling you a quiz ma'am yeah what
did you get out of us a little we're so
what I got one gang of it is that while
you're building even if you don't know
exactly what is the business endeavor
entrepreneurs ever that you're going to
build you can document your own personal
journey a fine
but so as long as you're being honest
about everything you're not putting our
[ __ ] and just fake it till you make
it and just really like hey I'm not
exactly sure I'm doing we're trying this
right now to see if this works if this
is a model that we can really get behind
if I'm working with somewhere myself
there I'm really interested in that
Kathy was pushing them and once you
build that then I'm gonna then I would
start building like you know maybe that
become an irrigator in social media
Siobhan that's exactly right in a lot of
ways and just some how many views do you
think if there was video of sucks
launching Facebook that day and the
conversation that him in those four or
five home he's had in their dorm room of
like what they like how many views do
you think that would have like really
like I mean like good drill Ian's bro
[ __ ] millions like you know like and so
that to me is super interesting and I
think that that's what your generation
and all you characters have and don't
waste it because you gonna be really
pissed even documented can I say one
thing about laughing I think two things
alright so 2009 I decided I wanted to be
a writer my first book didn't come out
for three four years after that and I
knew writers have email lists right
that's how you tell people you're
launching a book but why would anyone
subscribe to an email list from a person
they'd never heard of right and so I
thought how do I get people who like
books on an email list and so I said I'm
going to recommend books that I like and
my first email went out to 50 people it
was so small I could just copy them into
the baby yes and then that's how wine
library's entire email list was ten
years and then you find a way Gmail caps
it at a certain numbers like I was
resonating then I had to open or bring
water for me right now getting multiple
then I you know then I open like a
MailChimp account or something and I'm
at convertkit now but that list is now
85,000 people and the way I monitor I
just recommend one email a month just
books and I've monetized it because I've
sent six emails to that list of my where
the book I'm announcing that month is my
own book right and so so we you one of
the months would you recommend books it
is a good book using love it I like the
guy who goes yeah yeah and and it'll be
funny because people going
no idea they've been subscribed for
years and they'll be like I had no idea
you were writer I have a great idea for
your January 30th 2018 recommended book
it's called crushing it to follow up to
a book that did very well talk on Utley
dun dun no no definitely not done
because one thing you know what's funny
about you and this is crop you know it's
so fun you know I don't need a lot of
people that I have common friends with
and knew by reputation but met them kind
of late like it's funny that it took a
while for us to cross your path the
level of like I know it's not done
because it makes me so happy for you
it's the it's called respect that if you
don't like it it's not done even though
we may like each other it's why I will
recommend ashes right yeah it's why if
you notice the 5 or 6 times I've ever
given a quote to somebody's book it
never says anything about the book
because I don't time to read it and I
don't read and I can't read that's right
it says Amy's wonderful right it says
that it will never say like this book
made me think that's a good hack though
if you're ever writing a book and you're
asking for blurbs ask them to blurb you
because you can use the blurb for more
than just your book it's true Amy as
wonderful works on everything okay
thanks so much for calling brother good
luck know that thanks so much but I
remember how we met the first time I was
walking down the street in Austin sounds
laughs I we bumped into each other
I said hey Gary what's going on he said
nothing just crushing it right and
impressive it just came out I was like
that's a man no said a brand
I really enjoyed when we hung more
officially in Austin in the glamour I
was really looking forward having you on
the show man and I highly listen you
guys know me pretty well like you can
see I'm buddy-buddy with a lot of people
and I like a lot of people the list gets
a lot shorter when you when you ask me
like who do I think is good my good list
is a hell I like everybody weirdly who
do I think is good is a very short list
and I think you're really good at what
you do man thank you man for real
cool one last one like we're off camera
we really we think everyone sucks like
really sucks like SEP car sucks Josh
Gary B askgaryvee show you're on with
Ryan how are you Gary what is up I'm
good how you doing how you doing Ryan
I'm doing good what are you from what's
your question I am from Boston
Massachusetts so I'll get right into it
my question I have a baseball
subscription box company it's called
plate crates link crank I'm teetering
plate crate so I do a monthly box
baseball gear training it's accessories
I got about six hundred monthly
customers we're growing pretty rapidly
real quick I already lock you up real
quick on you but you have a box of the
month business that has baseball stuff
in it I know I'm simplifying it yep no
you've gone back to what it is keep
going baseball players not fans
I saw players high school play I assume
non-professional players right Little
League all the way up to professional we
have a couple pro guys as well not in
the MLB even in my league I love it keep
yeah so basically we're doing Facebook
Ads we do a ton on Instagram and
Facebook I just got into my affiliate
program but my affiliate program I only
give about 7 to 10 dollar commissions so
not super enticing for influencers I was
wondering how you get around that hurdle
well you could give them much more what
the answer was I better cut the lifetime
value your customers got to be way more
than six or seven dollars right because
he's new he doesn't know it's about
4,000 it's about foreign it it's about
four and a half months LTV so it's worth
more than that
cost of goods about half so what do you
know usually what are you just greedy or
no I'm not greedy I did like a tiered
system I could give more away I just
didn't know how to stretch it since I've
never done an affiliate program before
so I looked up it was about 20 20 to 30
percent it's really funny though I want
every single person listening to this
podcast to rewind this there was
something I tweeted the other day kind
of just like I've been on this kick
lately of just saying stuff very
generally just for my own happiness and
I said it was at their meeting where
somebody was clearly not passionate
about their product they were trying to
sell me and I tweeted something like you
know selling isn't scary a lot of people
are scared to sell its selling something
you don't believe in is scary if
everybody rewinds your the way you
talked about your affiliate program just
now was like you [ __ ] on it before you
even finish the fourth word out of your
mouth and I think it's a really
interesting insight right of course it
has me a prayer
you thought the affiliate program was
dog [ __ ] for the person and so like it's
like yeah it's a really interesting like
brah I'm telling you even for yourself
my man you need to go back and listen to
how you said it it was crazy
you hedged the living [ __ ] out of it
like hey guys real quick this really
sucks yet but give me an answer that is
self is the insight the thing that
always works for me and why I think I'm
a good salesman is boy do I believe in
my shin and if I don't I just don't sell
it and so like you know you like what's
the number that you think is really
worth it to them like when do you when
do you feel in Phatak about DMing every
little league baseball coach on earth
like when do you get pumped like what do
you think the good deal is and more
importantly if you why can't you make
that the deal if you think that is a
deal is it financial what is it and I
would say the deal should be so good
that it's a little scary to you right
that the number of a little scary and I
would say a couple other things on
affiliate program so one it's got to be
both directions right so what are you
giving them as the Commission and then
what are they offering their people
right so it's not like I'm not going to
I'm not going to get up and go hey I'm
going to sell this because I know I'm
taking some money off the back end I
want to be able to go to my people my
fans and and give them something you
look like wealthfront
I think one of the best affiliate
programs it's really good they manage
money for free but for both parties
right yes and and and then and then
remember like I see this I do this in
one of my talks where I got this letter
from from like my mortgage company
they're like hey we really appreciate
referrals give us referrals and I was
like I'm sure you do appreciate her for
a month it's funny but it's free
business right so pay pay me right like
thank you if you want you're asking
people to spend their social capital
recommending your for-profit service let
me throw another one mainly because I
respect Ryan I'm actually doing this
selfishly because I want to see what his
reaction is because I think you'll be
able to add on it where do you go
completely the other way sure right so I
think of things in brand and sales
transactional micro and macro brand
building maybe you go completely the
other way and go you know like to me a
lot of times it's like don't ask for
anything ever and just
obliviate everybody with like
value value value right like what have
you made the best baseball training
videos of all by free like like that's
where you act like a media company right
I've had yes so like there's a lot of
ways to go about it but the one thing to
never do is be half pregnant and like
that's we're stuck right now - Ryan's
point let me tell you something amazing
about controlling [ __ ] you can make it
as the affiliate program against seven
ten dollars yes seven to ten dollars and
how much is it a month it's thirty seven
dollars a month right
give them thirty seven dollars right I
mean let me know let me tell you why
mm-hmm because if you ask twenty nine
people and they all say yes cuz they're
like holy [ __ ] I'm getting as much as
he's getting in full sales I have great
news after they all say yes you can stop
giving that out yes like you're in
control your [ __ ] like I don't know put
in the fine print that it's like one day
you know cancellation to me it's like
like what people don't get is to Ryan's
points funny made me think about free
shipping like you know again I just love
pointing to Eric because you the story's
lost in history when we did free
shipping there was no like that's not
what happened like it was like we lost
like we were scared [ __ ] less we're like
whoa we're like no I mean limited free
shipping like what if they buy Kendall
Jackson that's dead cost you know we
lose money on the credit card
transaction let alone the [ __ ] but
like the good news was it expired it was
a one day thing like you could only put
us out of business so much and you know
I I don't know what you have in the bank
and what your situation is but - Ryan's
point if you make yourself uncomfortable
if it goes too well you can stop it
mm-hmm well no it's funny to like
businesses are willing to lose money on
all sorts of things right they're
willing to lose money on advertising
dollars so but it's good it's good for
brand building whatever and then if I
said okay but what if we gave $50,000
with a product away to people you like I
don't know and it's like the product is
the best advertising if the internet you
spend $50,000 on a billboard and maybe
you get some customers out of it first
you give $50,000 worth of product away
at least you have $50,000 worth of
people using your [ __ ] and if it's good
you'll get word-of-mouth Ryan there was
a delicious product coming out for one
of my clients delicious like I'm
I like everybody liked it all creeds and
and I told them instead of spending 4
million dollars on median marketing to
give away twenty four million dollars of
the product and they just couldn't wrap
their head around it no and it would've
worked I mean the gambling works
publishers want to try to charge media
outlets for you know first serial rights
on a book that's an excerpt it's like
are you out of your mind give as much of
the book away as humanly possible
and if it's good people will give the
book to other people how is going to buy
a book but they know nothing about that
they haven't gotten to try right until
you if your [ __ ] is good the more of it
you give away the more customers you'll
have I love it does that put you in the
macro mindset yeah absolutely I'm gonna
do that right now right when we get off
the phone
you better tweet us and tell us what
happened love you see it buy up I'm
sorry right what uh what party would I
mean you've got so much wisdom what
parting wisdoms for you know so many
entrepreneurs listening all shapes and
sizes I think we I think I think this is
going to be a very popular episode we
got into like some details which i think
is going to be very healthy for my
audience because I have boy do I love to
be in the macro what what like one other
two other tidbits like sit on your chest
on the theme of this episode anything
stand out I know you got a lot of
different things that you believe in
like anything that we haven't covered
that you think can be a nugget for
somebody want to take a sharp right turn
and talk you're gonna die a memento
mori' I think I think I carry in my
pocket every day I carry a coin that
just says memento mori' which is Latin
it means remember your death right on
the back there's a quote from Marcus
Aurelius to set the stoic and he wrote
to himself he said you could leave life
right now that should let that determine
what you do and say and think so
this could be the last it's the last
show I'm on in my life this could be the
last city I'm on in my life
this could be the last book I ever write
you know the last time I talked to my
wife could be the last time and you got
to let that determine you got to let
that shape debt should the thought of
your mortality and death in it and not
in a depressing way should shadow
everything that you do because it's the
only way to make sure you do it right
boy do I talk a death
a lot right right yeah I mean I mean at
the funeral like oh yes should I believe
in it the most as you can probably know
a little bit like I love I'm glad you
brought that up know your three words
you're going to die yeah actually that
should let you cut out [ __ ] that
should let you decide how you're going
to treat other people and let yourself
be treated and it should determine the
quality of the work that you're going to
happen to everybody in a micro it's
called what police lights go on behind
you you're scared shitless you change
your behavior then the car drives by you
right and then for like three minutes
you're like okay under 55 now and then
you know four minutes later you're going
73 again right and that's how I think
people do it in life like something bad
happens to he or something they see
something and they're like oh [ __ ] I'm
going to live under the mindset of
you're gonna die like yeah they see my
thing is hit them for a day well it's
like you hear about a friend who has
cancer and you think like what would I
do if I had kids right though
you do have cancer you're gonna [ __ ]
die I do have cancer you just don't you
just don't first off because lots of
people do it your cancer so there's a
real chance the cells or the cells are
already in your body right yeah but like
you do have a fatal diagnosis from a
doctor he just can't tell you if it's
six months or 60 years but you know are
definitely a hundred percent going to
die and it could be tomorrow so what are
you going to do with that information I
believe in it the most my man yeah
alright question of the day okay every
guest gets to ask the question a day
you'll get a lot of answers thousands
across Facebook and YouTube most likely
this is a good opportunity for you do
little you know focus group or or or
whatever the hell you like I so I'm so
that's a question to the audience and be
more than welcome to ask me a single
review a question okay so and then you
can ask the question a day so I love
writing and books and all that and it's
what up it's what gets me up in the
morning and one of the things I wrestle
with when I watch your stuff and I see
this the immense amount of people you're
reaching as I see video and social and
all this stuff and I I ask myself
on the one hand I didn't become a writer
to go do those things right all those
things come at the cost of my craft but
on the other hand am I being closed
month like how could someone like me gig
in the video you put that form of
communication in that
next on a pedestal because of the
narrative you painted yourself early on
sure the end okay you know like I get it
like I think about it too like it's
funny how the world goes in your favor
when you just realize what's the point
I think what's special about you for me
so I actually think you have something
to say it's interesting I've spent some
time with you now second time little
meanness it's always [ __ ] strong and
look you may be great you are great at
communicating those things in your way
yeah and that still may be your way I
for example can't put three sentences
together
but I know that people like to read
books sure right right and so for me i
hack the system for me it's a
ghostwriter for me it's try to really be
smart about my process like and I'm able
to write a book in my voice because
every word is dissected every it's all
recorded right grammar instructors put
around to help me but I don't put the
medium on a platform
I put the message on a platform and then
I figure out how to hack whether audio
video or written word how to get it out
there because I feel in my heart and
this is what I get from you that I'm
really trying to bring value
I love the narcissistic and selfish
aspects of it but I'm Way more
fascinated by the legacy and noble
altruistic aspects of it which then
gives me the humility to deploy it in
any shape or form you may not be as
great at video in front of a camera but
you can absolutely work with somebody
who takes words and sentences and makes
it into an animation like you could
create a billion dollar IP business of
the cartoon version of yourself like
there's so many ways to do it video
consumption is real yeah
audio consumption is real your voice is
too powerful not to find its way into
those mediums no I should have this is
the way that you if you don't your books
are natural you find a way to get it
done or I need to do that on other
medium I don't at least my point of view
be done oh that's because I am looking
for because I think the romance of the
medium meh pathetic - yeah yeah but why
not let more people be affected by it no
you're you're totally right and then it
becomes a gateway to those things sure
sure I mean you'll have a lot more book
sumption if people have the video
consumption because that's what they're
doing you're totally right all right
question is ad audience uh what's the
book that changed your life that I
should read I'll get a lot of answers
and I'll try to read as many of them as
I can I believe you
yeah thanks such a pleasure yeah really
enjoy this you keep asking questions
we'll keep answering them
[Music]